i signed my sleep apnea mask and it
comes with humidifier
tubing and that's a big thing i don't
know if anybody's into sleep apnea
by the way it's not
sleep apnea is not square i want to tell
the kids it's not a square
thing it's cool sleep apnea is cool now
a lot of people say there's all kinds of
sexual [ __ ]
you know role playing that you could do
with the sleep apnea mask
having sleep apnea that's a sign of
wealth
it is without
you oh you you can eat and drink
to a level like nobody in those uh third
world countries like no they don't sell
those down there people don't have sleep
apnea what there's not a lot of food
down there
all right but i'm [ __ ] grown all your
clothes here
were made in a sweatshop all right if
you gave a [ __ ]
you would have made your own shirts
tonight i gave a [ __ ]
you'd be making your own clothing i have
a loom